[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
yeah all right what's up my name is
Robert Kelly and I'm here doing two
Comics two cigars and I believe Arizona
I believe Phoenix
add foxes Fox Cigar Lounge and cigar
shop I'm I'm here in Scottsdale sorry
Scottsdale and I'm here with the great
Rob dukes and you're sitting there going
isn't that the dude who sings metal
isn't that the guy lead singer of Exodus
isn't that the guy who who Generation
Kill Generation Kill of course
Generation Kill new album out now he's
not a comedian it's supposed to be two
comics and two cigars that's it not
three Comics not one comic and a lead
singer to a metal band yeah but guess
what and Ari's gonna hate this he's
gonna be [ __ ] but I don't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] art you know how those people
get yeah those people get off of the
yeah they do they get uptight about
things they want structure yeah and you
know what but you did stand up I did you
started how many years ago two two years
ago on stage right here microphone in
Arizona yes and you did it a bunch of
times yeah you're gonna continue to do
it yeah so yeah he might be an open
Miker pretty much instead stand-up world
and in metal you're a God but in stand
up you're a comic and that makes you a
comic so welcome to two Comics two
cigars two cigars that's right and today
we're smoking a beast beast I mean this
cigar is expensive yes it's uh 32 bucks
yep maybe 35 with tax
Ashton
uh Ashton it's a vsg eclipse eclipse
yeah yeah this cigar comes in a metal
tube yeah metal tube it's all special
packaging
um
it's it's an awesome cigar and my friend
Paul G shout out to Paul G boys at the
uh the Cigar Lounge Paul G
um told me he gave me this cigar one
night I always I'm coming to this lounge
and I'm like you got a cigar for me and
he's never he never gives me just
average he always I'll come out to be
sitting up like this in the tube I mean
that tube I come up and he'll be sitting
there hanging and this is just sitting
there and I go is this for me he goes
smoke that just smoke that smoke it and
I smoked it and it knocked my it knocked
my dick off yeah I met my dick fella I
had to pick my dick up off the ground so
you want to hear my vsg story yeah all
right because mine was my dick fell off
I hope yours is that you put that in
your ass
I actually know but what I did was I
made the hole of my dick what I do is I
my boyfriend your boyfriend he needed he
wanted to [ __ ] my dick I started out
with a double A battery right and I had
to work my way up but this is how so
this is how it is now yeah that's great
yeah it's absolutely happy for you yeah
so that's why you're taking your tomb
haul yeah I'm taking that home that's
fantastic so my vsg story is uh no
that's in it no so Bobby Kelly
Bobby Kelly started me uh smoking cigars
uh five years ago right I didn't know I
haven't I quit smoking cigarettes like
15 years ago 20 years ago so I was
afraid a cigar was gonna make me small
you were going through a thing yeah I
was in the middle of my divorce yeah or
starting to me yeah so and you were we
were in a thing so you said well come to
my podcast we'll talk and uh we smoked a
cigar
and then uh it was an Ashton vsg but it
was not the eclipse it was just a
regular uh it was a good one yeah the
five by fifty right so then
um about a month later I walked back
into I found a cigar lounge near my
house I walked in and I bought the vsg
the same one we smoked and then I smoked
this one yeah uh which was right next to
it and then I uh I realized that uh you
know thirty dollars a day times you know
two that's that's an expensive hobby you
need to yeah you need to own like a
restaurant right so I needed to figure
out what I what I like too so I ended up
smoking everything in the humidor to
figure out what I liked and there's a
few that I that I stick to but this is
like a this is like a twice a month this
is a hanging out with a good friend yes
you haven't seen each other in a minute
yep let's smoke something good and enjoy
it absolutely let's not take a risk yes
that you might not like this yeah or it
might be this so your taste buds get
whacked out yeah this cigar from here to
here is great around 35 bucks but you're
gonna love it so let's like these
suckers up yeah now the way we do it
we're going to talk about it at the
beginning in the middle and the end
wherever the end is it doesn't have to
be the end of the cigar yeah and then
we're gonna rate it none one five or a
box
at the end but in the middle we talk
about whatever the hell we want yeah
when we were talking about my special
kill box on Lewis ck.com and if you
watch this and you haven't got that you
should die in a fiery Bernie death of
hell I really liked it yeah you did I
did awesome I was actually the the the
Mac story had me I mean I was choking so
hard that I my friends are like you all
right dude because I couldn't catch my
breath I was laughing so I have like a
little Lounge like this in my house and
we watched it on a big TV and I have a
bunch of friends over and we all watched
it together and it was it was uh it was
great man yeah I love that thank you for
doing that damn man
yeah not many friends thank each other
for [ __ ] anymore no like uh
you know you just go that's cool
you know you shake a friend's hand once
in a while give them a hug yeah give
them a hug you want it no we can't wait
kiss his neck wow
when you kiss a guy's neck it's raped I
feel I would feel raped that's what I
don't hear a great story please tell me
all right so please tell me it's a race
so obviously I was a guitar player in
this like uh punk rock band
and my singer was like this good looking
dude who like dude was an okay singer he
was pretty you know he was all right but
uh the the chicks liked him you know I
mean he was a good looking dude so
um I was uh you know
just playing guitar on the band so
anyway he he booked this gig for us at
this private party
and he's like yeah it's this dude's
house he hit me up like I ran into him
and he books a gig at this at this house
way Upstate New York and it's supposed
to be like a kegger whether it's going
to be a kegger is a keg party up there
we get up there and it's it's three of
his buddies and we're set up on a on a
[ __ ] carpet in the backyard and it's
three of his friends and and I said to
him and I got you know I just so I go
dude this is extremely weird you know
that right and he's like well he's
paying us I'm like well I thought it was
a kegger like you know I mean like this
you know what I mean and anyway so
that's it it was just his three friends
oh it wasn't I thought that's the end of
the story we played two minutes no no we
played two minutes and then at the end
he went we packed up our gear we're like
the [ __ ] out of here and we're all mad
except him he goes to and the guy goes
to give him a hug and as the guy gave
him a hug he slipped a [ __ ] kiss on
his neck wow and it just like creeped
him out and just like so the whole time
it was a it was a guy trying to to bang
my singer yeah yeah yeah I had that same
thing happened to me when I was doing my
fifth step with a priest no [ __ ] yeah he
kissed me on the neck at the end
yeah soft kick wasn't it
was it was it meant for your cheek like
like you sound like hell you know nope
nope it was definitely it was a big nice
wet neck kiss huh yeah right at the end
of my fifth step wow yeah in his little
room in the record
I mean he had soft lips yeah
so
I uh I was at a I was at a meeting sorry
for the noise too by the way we have a
[ __ ] uh the landscape is a kicking
ass over there so there's noise but I'm
sure is everything still looking all
right all right good I had a I had a I
had a priest uh oh please tell me so
I I was going to meetings I was I was in
a in a in a rehab yeah right you're on
rehab yeah went to rehab I mean I've
seen it shockingly looking at you yeah
everybody's like yeah why would you not
be a rehab I was in rehab right right
and I was uh
I was uh in my late teens I got arrested
so they put me in a rehab because I was
I had drugs on me and was drunk so they
instead of putting me in jail they're
like let's give them a rehab stint you
know what I mean so
um I'm in rehab and they used to put us
on a van and take us to this church for
a meeting like twice a week right right
and the priest that ran the whole thing
was this dude and he was always there
and he he would always be real nice to
me and this other kid
and then one day he was like he just it
was he goes come here I want to talk to
you he goes you know dude you know if
you want I can I can have you you know
if you want to come to the church more
often I can talk to the the rehab and
have you you know come here more you
know uh because you got you know you got
some big muscles and he grabbed my arm
like this yeah
and uh if I just Flex it just creeped me
the [ __ ] out just [ __ ] Flex right
you're touching me so do it again do it
again so not bad yeah that's better
right so he he did that to me and uh and
I was like I was like you and and uh in
uh Fourth of July I just went get the
[ __ ] off me really and I was like you
mother like [ __ ] you man and I
I went and I told the the people at the
rehab
right you rat
[ __ ] that guy man ah you're rapping Todd
molesting [ __ ]
like the rest of us they brought us in
front of a whole Council a bunch of
priests me right and they were they were
all believing him and I stood up in the
room I was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you know what you [ __ ] did he just
kept denying it you lying [ __ ] and he
touched your arm dude he was trying to
get to my penis yeah but he look at this
here's the rule you ready yeah unless he
touches your Pekka you got to let
everything else slide I let the guy who
kiss me in the next slide look yeah
it was it
I'm not even saying like oh I was doing
it to protect the ones but that were
coming next yeah you know what I mean no
I was just [ __ ] you I was angry about it
[ __ ] that guy yeah I get it you're I
would have let it slide oh I would have
been like hey man listen no
I would have pointed him in the right
direction no see Jason over there he's
into this [ __ ] okay
with something yeah so let's talk about
this what do you think I mean right out
of the gate it's a heavy cigar it's not
a little it's this is a big boy one full
body it's a big boy full body it's a big
boy
it's uh yeah it's uh
is there a definitely want to eat
breakfast is your parade coming
you definitely want to eat first before
you smoke this
or uh
definitely want to eat first yeah drink
some coffee I I don't I don't drink
alcohol so it's just coffee for me yeah
people don't know that when you get when
you smoke a bat if it's gonna be a heavy
cigar like this you got to have a full
stomach you gotta have sugar in your
body you have a really [ __ ] up one
from yeah dude I've just gotten sick
yeah the cure to it I tell it all the
time on the show is yeah a piece of
candy a Jolly Rancher the sugar will
neutralize the nicotine can of Coke yeah
a can of Coke something like that yeah
uh always same thing if you go to dim
sum and you stuff your face yeah with
dims I have Coke after it settles it
down I don't know why it works I I I
missed dim sum yeah this is but look at
look at that I mean look at that it's
nice it's heavy though listen this is
when you like some cigars what happens
to me is I'll start when it's a mild
cigar I'll smoke through it in 20
minutes oh yeah this slows you the [ __ ]
down that's why I like a heavier cigar
once in a while yeah it slows you the
[ __ ] down and you can feel that role
it's soft and tight like my [ __ ] I I
smoke a Connecticut in the morning and
then I uh and then I immediately
switched to uh medium to fulls you
forgot about jerking off you're smoking
scar then you jerk off
and then
you jerk off anymore
um I haven't in months
you wanna know why yeah why would I not
I got a girl
like hey what's up
okay I understand that so you just make
her do it yep I mean jerking off no I
don't know just
I just have I do it
almost uh I'm gonna say I don't know
four days a week I I actually like four
or five days a week she's right there by
the way everybody she's behind the
camera it's hilarious four or five days
you're talking about like you hired a
migrant worker to do your backyard and
watch your kids I found myself being a
little creepy where I would just I
wouldn't say anything I would just come
in and I'd kind of just lay there and um
and then
she'd be like she actually sending me I
guess I know what I'm having for
breakfast this morning and I was like
yeah for breakfast yeah Jesus Christ
dude before she even got nutrients you
gave her protein
wow
yeah dude that's nuts yeah I don't I
don't I might if I tried to get a
[ __ ] from my wife before she woke Max
up she would tell me to go [ __ ] myself
she'd probably call me kid kid go [ __ ]
your mother
I'm a lucky dude I guess but you don't
miss I love
the hunt
of like you know getting the finding the
like finding what gets you whacked and
get you off like you go from here you
know you're over at real maids all of a
sudden you're over the massage then
you're over the [ __ ] uh best friend's
mom catches you and you're going through
all this stuff and then you find the one
the scenario that just this I know this
is it the setup is perfect and you you
got it out you've been edging for like
20 minutes and then all of a sudden you
hit play you widescreen it you let it
play out and beige I'm professional I
have the towel now half wet half dry I'm
in and out 20 minutes I mean the whole
process 20 minutes yeah 20 minutes all
right I like it I like I know all right
here's the deal first thing you have to
make you ever like not leave your
glasses next to your bed and then you
got to go find your [ __ ] reading
glasses so you can see your phone to
jerk off like yeah so that's the you
know that's happened oh I'm gonna joke
not on my reading glasses [ __ ] it I'm
just gonna get up and start my day
um
so
um mine is uh mine is lesbian porn but
it's from the 70s where they have the
story which has never done it before
I've never had a massage before and then
yeah those are my brother the sleepover
I love when they usually act yeah
usually try even though they couldn't
they tried that's really they read the
script they made choices as an actress
yeah and they [ __ ] did it now it's
just like hey and I dude is it anything
worse with some hot chick is into this
you know some type of thing and then she
giggles
she giggles in the scene she breaks
character it's like I'm out next one
yeah back in there the only thing but
they and they have the big caveman
bushes back then I like those
I like it auto it looks like this yeah I
don't know
uh no I yeah
I don't mind him I just due to the story
is what gets me I love the story the
story is like a big [ __ ] story guy
dude yeah I uh yeah dude I need I need
because I'm going there for the scenario
I'm going there to escape and have a
little fantasy yeah I'm not going to
jerk off I wanna that whatever that
scene is whatever that scenario is I
want to really live it yeah if it's a
massage if it's a lesbian thing
sleepover if it's a cop thing yeah if
it's a you know a dominant she male
takes over you I only watch [ __ ] porn
tickets two guys in the woods that just
catch camping and [ __ ] happened right
all of a sudden yeah you watch what I
watch trending porn to catch my friends
you ever seen the like I want to just
catch my friends in it like throwing a
charity porn so that's the only reason I
watch it yeah that's a good one I like
that one I use that one yeah I I do
research yeah just so I can be closer to
just want to catch my friends I knew I
saw you in that [ __ ] porn you know you
know how many training porns I watched
to catch you on that one dude wanna hear
[ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] friend
no I'm kidding
Jason my friend Jason one time I'm
[ __ ] jerking off running through the
whole
thing right clipping through the you
know how the little the little Windows
right they have the little you know just
this
so it's the the it's the guy in the
corner while his wife gets [ __ ] by
another guy yeah love those yeah my
friend Jason is the guy in the corner he
got paid to be the guy in the corner and
I just I just turned my phone off I was
like dude so he had to watch he was in a
point right it was it was just a guy in
the corner acting like the his wife was
being [ __ ] by somebody else and uh and
I called him up immediately and I'm like
you [ __ ] you ruined my jerk how
but how good was his acting
I I watched it for about eight seconds
and I was like dude my friend I'll watch
it my friend ruined my
um I'll see if I can get him to send it
to me he probably have he's he's such a
narcissistic [ __ ] that he probably
has it like in his phone kept like yo
here's part of my reel here's one of my
my real things you know that I did I
mean look if it was good acting it's
good acting it doesn't matter you know
what I mean acting is acting that gets
you when uh the the uh yeah you're
getting a sag because you played a good
cuck
you write that down I could juggle I can
ride a bike play guitar and I'm a great
cuck
landscapers I mean he's been working on
the same Bush what do you what is it art
I mean enough
yeah it's a shitty building he's not
even making dinosaurs
like you see you've never seen one of
our dinosaurs and [ __ ] that people do
that he's not even doing that no he's
just I mean that's just nuts shut it
down
the loudest this is the loudest two
Comics two cigars ever made
you're a Metalhead I saw it I already
did one on us he does it on the on the
was it outside on this fire escape he's
got a deck it's a fire escape it's a no
it's a deck is it yeah he's got oh no
the fire that was his old apartment oh
he did oh yeah he did one with a big Jay
I saw that yep yeah yeah
Artie's [ __ ] funny
I mean he's not gonna like this I don't
care okay good I'm just saying I don't
care they don't like it good [ __ ] you
Ari say [ __ ] you though [ __ ] you already
but you like him yeah I do I I was I was
hoping that he would want to sit down
and ask me about metal and I could give
him the inside scoop I'll be let me be
all right all right okay
you can do his voice
oh sure sure
uh what were you saying yeah so what
about uh Rob uh I have notes
um I want to ask you about Metal tell me
about Metal yeah do you like metal I
[ __ ] hate it I wish that's not true
I've heard you'd say that I'm kidding
Rob I'm joking you're on acid and you
listen to Black Sabbath and you like
this is the greatest band ever because
you're oh that's that part of his uh he
was at UFC and and the fighter came out
to Black Sabbath and he was stoked so
yeah I love metal yes I love it okay
don't give me direction again I'm my own
[ __ ] actor okay uh
I don't know man I mean you what are
your questions I don't know tell me how
it is I really want to know how how do
you keep your voice I don't understand
how you're screaming yeah you're
screaming yeah so it's scream singing
top of your lungs
and you have to do that over and over
again and you're on a tour yeah over and
over again now is there a difference
between what you do on stage in front of
a live crowd and when you're in a studio
yeah explain that that's a good question
thank you Ari for such a good question
write in the comments Ari great question
great question in a studio
um you are uh I'm just speaking from my
personal experience so you don't speak
from somebody else I've made five
records right and wow when I when I've
um make a record
um
each song is about a day so you get
about I screaming at the top of my lungs
at a hundred and is you know 150 I'm
just until until I'm on the breaking
point of losing my voice you know what I
mean so uh in the studio you're giving
it your all because that's what people
are hearing like you know what I mean
um so you can do that for about two
hours sometimes three depending on how
you map out the song some songs are
harder than others some songs are maybe
the the pitch is a little higher maybe
the the the the growling is a little
more in the middle so you can kind of
like get through the more work of it so
what I do is I kind of map out okay I'm
gonna do these three courses today and
then I know I'm gonna be done I'm going
to spend right um
whereas live
um
I I don't really know what other people
do I know that I just uh I don't I have
a natural ability to not lose my voice
okay
um I don't know why I don't rehear I
don't warm up I don't cool down I just I
just go out and do it and um but I've
learned uh like it's like it's like
riding a motorcycle I know where my
limitations are and what I can do and
what I can do okay and so what I do is I
make the set list a certain way because
some songs are really hard and I usually
do them in the beginning to get them out
of the way and then I can kind of um the
other stuff I that's not so hard is at
the end is in a you know is at the end
so well what if the hit song is at the
end then you're [ __ ] it's kind of the
what I did I actually the the hardest
song I ever have to sing is a song
called there is no hope and it's on the
Generation Kill record we're all gonna
die and it's the second to last song
very upbeat album yeah right it's very
upbeat it makes you feel good does it
feel good feel good record yeah
everybody's gonna die there's no hope
and uh the third track on that album
yeah uh dead babies that's a it's a good
one your grandmother will die yeah the
fifth track yep hey it's the hardest
song I've ever wrote really why the
chorus oh there's some reason the chorus
it's just like going in the studio I did
it and then uh when the first time I did
it live I was like uh oh I'm gonna make
a new rule on this podcast yeah if your
Chicago's out you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah
is that out no okay I'm just gonna make
a rule of that okay okay that can I just
another little tip a good cigar you can
tell even when you don't smuggle for a
little bit it's still lit and it burns
evenly around yeah that's the hint of a
good cigar right there yeah I'm not a
fan of the long Ash all right
he has a tattoo of rage on his hand so
I'll just listen I'll just tap it out
yeah well I have this I don't know
what's that passion yeah I was talking
today on the radio
that God invented passion
because it helps you get over the smell
of sex
you know because sex just stinks it's
just
waiting tables eight hours she went out
to the dance club you went you went to
Applebee's now you're back at the house
and just you need that [ __ ] well I want
to eat that [ __ ] to get over that that
pungent
when the butthole juice and the ash the
[ __ ] juice just met and formed a new
juice and you're like I don't give a
head I don't care you're down there of
course you don't care huh you have a
beard too it gets stuck in your mouth oh
man you know what the best is
she she used to come over and I'd eat
ass the whole [ __ ] she's right there
yeah right and then and then uh and I go
to work the next morning I put on my
motorcycle helmet and the smell would be
inside my helmet I'm gonna throw it and
I would I would just I'd have to I
almost want to leave work so I could
[ __ ] have her meet me back at the
house and do it again yeah okay
all right thanks yeah um all right
that's uh two Comics too she holy [ __ ]
so let's talk about comedy real quick
all right um scariest thing I've ever
done really now you if people don't know
this you were in Exodus you are the guy
who did that what do they call it them
the Wall of Death the Wall of Death that
was you that was me okay so if you want
to go to YouTube Type in Wall of Death
and this guy will be on stage
commanding
a bunch of kids to to
Smash and kill each other in a the Wall
of Death yeah which is one of the most I
mean dude I don't care if you don't like
metal it's pretty powerful you see that
yeah and here you are doing that in
front of those fans yeah and you're
saying stand-up comedy is the scariest
thing you've ever done the scariest
thing on it so I was saying to uh I did
120 000 people multiple times I did I
opened up for Iron Maiden at a soccer
stadium in Santiago Chile in front of 85
000 people [ __ ] and uh
I was at this little place in Scottsdale
50 people
walking to the stage
with to do stand up for the first time
yeah it was one of the most terrifying
things I've ever done yeah why
I I don't because I didn't have a band
behind me because it was just me in the
microphone and that dead [ __ ] silence
and watching all the [ __ ] losers go
on before me you know
um
now
um I don't know why
but I have this thing even though I'm
kind of scary looking I'm also I almost
seem a little bit likeable
so
I think if the crowd kind of likes you
they're gonna let you get away with more
yeah you look like Santa Claus with a
heroin addiction yeah
so yeah like you're actually you know
what's I was coming home from Florida I
went and saw my mom and I
getting on the plane I walk around I'm
at the gate I walk around the gate and I
come around the corner and this little
kid goes Santa
screamed it I was like yeah what's up
like a look man I'm on vacation relax
right and then and then he was getting
out of hand him and his brothers were
[ __ ] I go I walked over there I go
hey
you guys Mama [ __ ] are they being good
she's like no they're not I'm going good
I'm keeping a record and then I walk
back to my chair that's great and scared
the [ __ ] up finally it's fantastic this
is exactly the way Santa would look
though yeah did you see the new Santa
movie coming out no uh the guy from
um um well what the [ __ ] is that stupid
kid show on Netflix
stranger things the cop I don't know
I've never watched stranger things of
course because you're a man and I'm a
child and I've watched all five seasons
um great that makes me feel good
um he was in um he played Hellboy the
second Hellboy oh Rana yes yeah no no no
not the first guy the second one the
Hellboy guy no but the snout I gave you
the wrong guy
um Beauty and the Beast guy nope
nope anyways new Santa Claus coming out
who's a who kicks ass this family gets
taken hostage by John Lit uzamo I don't
know how that happens he's five two yeah
you know he's chubby but anyways him and
a crew people go to this Rich family's
house take over the place and Santa
Claus comes down the chimney at the same
time and just [ __ ] kills everybody to
save the family which I I think that's
that's where we're at as a society we
can't even just have regular Santa
anymore we need Santa that [ __ ] beats
the [ __ ] out of bad guys yeah which is
great I think it's great I'm all right
with that I am too yeah um all right so
you're doing stand-up you go up there
for the first time how'd you do I did
okay I actually uh called you
immediately after oh yeah yeah
um
and uh that's a comic thing by the way
yeah as soon as you do a show you call
another comic just to ground yourself
yeah to hear it's good that happens yeah
it's almost like uh AAA and then and
then I sent you the next uh I I videoed
the next two or three and send them to
you for your critique and um the one
could so I I so you know what you know
what was crazy is I had I don't know if
I don't know if I'd written it down I
wasn't writing anything down but I was I
was thinking about it in my head before
I went on right yeah and before uh but
as I was walking to the comic before me
said something and as I was walking to
to go up next
I the first thing I do is I commented on
something he had said well yeah
huh what do you say
he said he was uh he he got caught uh
watching granny porn
and he gave up the website and I I
walked up and I immediately said well I
don't want to be here I want to go home
immediately and watch to go to that
website granny porn.net or whatever it
was and everyone laughed right right and
um and then everything I had had said
that I had ready to say
um didn't happen out the window I just
started talking about whatever and
normally so it was a five minute thing
and normally they would give you a light
um but the owner of the club didn't give
me the light and I kept going I went to
like eight minutes and he said you were
being funny so I didn't I didn't like it
wow that never happens yeah usually they
come down on you for that [ __ ] no he
goes no I let you go because you were
being funny oh good yeah and then he
wanted me to sign up for his class
there you go yeah did you no why
uh cause uh because you're not a [ __ ]
yeah I'm just gonna learn this on my own
dude yeah yeah I had people say that to
me when I when I was a I got into an
argument with uh with a guy in the band
he was like you know you should
you know what you're saying on stage I
was new at it like I'd never been a
singer in my life and all of a sudden I
was singing in front of thousands of
people every night right and he's like
yeah you know you should watch this guy
and that guy and you know try to
cultivate you I was like yeah let me
just kind of just be myself
and I didn't listen to him and he uh he
had that it was a resentment and we
never got along again really yeah no
[ __ ] I almost beat him up well I mean
why because he got drunk and got my face
okay I was like dude man you didn't need
to go to bed he's like oh you need to go
to bed dude or you're gonna I'm Gonna
Knock your [ __ ] teeth out so go to
bed really he actually woke up next
morning and said I apologize I was
really drunk I go yeah you were and you
were [ __ ] out of line right so
you want to be a singer goes to be a
singer in a band you're a [ __ ]
drummer right play the [ __ ] drums
leave me alone well it's funny because
stand up I believe
you know if you if you'll watch people
when you go to clubs yeah you'll see
other people that you admire and you
will there's always I think people say
oh he's doing that guy a lot of
comedians wind up doing the guys that
they love yeah on the way to becoming
themselves yeah you know what I mean so
I really do not
um I don't I don't I used to be like
what now I get it we all kind of become
something on the neck on the way to the
next thing yeah you know and that's what
you your thing is you got to take the
band off and it's not so weak yeah it's
really on there
um I should probably take a picture
of this yeah we'll do that okay
um we'll take a picture all right so
let's talk about this real quick in the
middle yeah I'm in the middle what do
you think I love the cigars and like I
said
there's there's a few cigars that are
really special
because they're expensive so it's not
like I can I don't have the I don't I
don't have the living where I can do
them all the time yeah but this is like
once or twice a month
yeah right
yeah I wish I could buy a box of these
and smoke them like like I'll give you a
review out yeah no no but I would bury
the lead I would I would smoke these all
the time if I if I had that kind of loot
yeah I read an article Giuliani just
bought twelve thousand dollars worth of
cigars I'm like
it's not really that much they're about
120 120 cigars probably for a month yeah
yeah it's not a big deal yeah he smokes
in the um
it's the uh 666 at Rockefeller Center I
believe it is it's a private Lounge
upstairs yeah
you have to wear a shirt and tie to get
in ah shoes
and uh you have to be a member you have
to be invited yeah I remember and um no
my friend MO who's tattooed while he
rapper love about his friend uh Phil
invited us up me into Aaron Berg and I
went up there dude and they bring out
lamb chops like the best Lamb Chop I've
ever had in my life yeah uh anything you
want and you're sitting like giuliani's
behind you uh you know just famous
people everywhere yeah like just smoking
in a high-rise building did you ask how
much the membership was no no no no no
but I met dude I met some I met so many
high-end people yeah and that's why I
love cigars what were they smoking they
were smoking you know I don't know
whatever you know what I mean satawajes
they were smoking tats like me and the
guy Phil and motor was smoking's hats
like it's had to smoke a sauce I do and
good score but we were I mean it's just
funny because cigars
even the playing field on anything when
you're sitting in a lounge doesn't
matter who the [ __ ] there you're
having the same conversation or not just
chilling yeah you know and nobody's a
dick
nobody's an [ __ ] no I've met some
[ __ ] oh cigars yeah but
I'm talking like in this situation what
do you mean you met [ __ ] that was a
dick oh he's just a dick he's a loud
obnoxious know-it-all [ __ ] douche and
he comes in he comes into cigar lounge
every now and again and I I [ __ ]
avoid him because he's a [ __ ] douche
what do you do he's just so loud
obnoxious Mr [ __ ] know-it-all [ __ ]
douche yeah yeah okay well I was wrong
it actually comes in mostly on football
nights okay yeah but you know that's you
yeah so let me let me let me
I'm gonna go out of Tangier a little bit
here yeah please go ahead
I don't like doing this because it makes
me seem like a little bit of a but I
want to thank you
for introducing me into cigars okay
because you did and and what they've
done to my life is not only they is
smoking a good cigar
is one of the most
relaxing
um it it almost brings me back to center
with my life I've been able to
accomplish so much because I was able
just to [ __ ] take an hour because I
can't do anything else when I smell I
can't play golf I can't run around I
can't drive my car I just smoke sitting
in a [ __ ] nice comfortable chair but
a nice cup of coffee and I [ __ ] smoke
right and you gave me that and I needed
it especially because I was going
through divorce and I came out the other
side but also I met like this group of
guys that I [ __ ] hang out with at my
local cigar bar
that I never would have met in my whole
life I never would have had one guy is
like he's a retired homicide detective
the other guy is a [ __ ] real estate
agent and they they I would never be
friends with these people had it not
been this common thing and it uh it just
I'm so [ __ ] stoked that I found this
in my life because I needed it yeah I
you know I found the same thing
when I moved up to Westchester I'm
living away from the city I have a son
all this pressure and then I found the
cigar Republic which is my club and I
met Yuri who I love and then I met all
these other guy you know uh Paul G I met
you know uh Remy and Eddie and Oscar and
the boys and I mean it's just a yeah
Lounge full of guys yeah that when I go
in hey man what's up how's it there
conversation cool yeah you know uh Rob
the cop I met cops and restaurant tours
and and real estate mobile I mean guys
who have a little money and guys who
have a ton of cash I mean yeah all walks
of life that was my point yeah when you
walk in even the even the dick head yeah
there is you know there's always that
one guy yeah but you know whatever yeah
move it along you stay away but to be a
member of a cigar lounge to have your
own humidor to walk in to share cigars
to have them share and sit around watch
a movie watch just shoot the [ __ ] and
smoke for an hour
an hour and a half two hours maybe all
night sometimes yeah it is [ __ ] great
it's our version of the VFW the Elks
Club the French Club yeah which are you
know still around but not as popular
with young guys also like I never uh I
never uh I quit drinking before I had
the opportunity to you know you know the
guys that like that go to a bar every
day after work and I stop and have a
couple drinks and then they go home like
I never understood that because I never
did it because I was too young when I
quit drinking so like the uh the the
idea of going to sit at a bar just never
appealed to me right yeah yeah until I
found a cigar bar my bar is the yard
Cigar Bar in Chandler Arizona it's right
outside Phoenix it's [ __ ] mellow it's
cool
um Eric the owner is [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] great guy you know and my buddy
Brad great guy yeah yeah they all came
to your show last year and we all hung
out we went there after and then we went
to the other place and then uh and drank
over there and had a [ __ ] blast last
yeah man yeah man that's the I love it
it's almost like you're absolutely right
it's like the same feeling as going to a
bar and I don't drink either but going
hanging out like we're at skank Fest the
last weekend yeah and what I like to do
is find the area where we're smoking
get and all you need is a couple chairs
a couple things of water or drinks and a
couple people and we form this little
right in the middle of the merch where
people could come over and get photos
but we were they were all there we were
over here just smoking and and talking
and philosophizing and right there's
nothing better uh than that to me
because it's like I'll do my set and
I'll me and Joe list I'll meet you over
there with smoking Ari yeah uh you know
Aaron bird and then people come over
there you don't know smoke you get an
extra one yeah and they'll light up and
we all hanging out just smoking cigars
it's a conversational time timer yeah
like this is this is done it's like all
right let's go I went and I did uh I did
a podcast with Greg Fitzsimmons and I
went I did it at his house in his
backyard and I brought [ __ ] two uh
padrone 64s and we [ __ ] smoked up and
we [ __ ] had a great talk and it was
awesome man it was great he actually uh
gave me a beautiful humidor a suitcase
assume in a little suitcase no [ __ ] yeah
I use my studio for a couple months when
he was filming his TV show in New York
at the cellar and I was like yeah
[ __ ] go ahead and he used it and uh
at the end he's such a good guy he's
great one of one of Greg Simmons
funniest dudes walking absolutely I mean
murderer yeah I mean murder precise
jokes but you don't even know you're
being told jokes yeah he just goes into
the store and he's so [ __ ] you know
what I mean like hilariously so I went
to I went to is this guy Gonna Fly I
mean this guy's already he's the best
landscaper ever yeah he's been over two
hours I mean there's nine cactuses over
there what do you got to do yeah so uh I
go and visit Greg right we do this
podcast and then he goes come to the
store tonight yeah so I go to the
[ __ ] store me and Mel right and uh
he he introduced me to the crowd which
was I didn't want him like he was It was
kind of weird but it was it but I stood
up I said hey what's up and then I
watched Ian Edwards go up another killer
dude Ian Edwards killed Ian Edwards is
one of the best crowd of work guys ever
dude like fastest fastest lightning he
was awesome man no no nothing I'm
thinking Ian bags sorry Ian Edward's
[ __ ] hilarious yes so then the three
of us we was a white guy from Canada
from Africa no he's from uh where he's
from uh Jamaica Jamaica okay Jamaica uh
yeah so uh Ian hilarious
um funny as [ __ ] so we're standing
outside and he's like oh what are you in
town for and I was like oh I'm here to
see uh Chappelle's uh gig on Thursday at
the Hollywood Bowl and this is Wednesday
night he goes ah cool he goes uh yeah
come on me so he [ __ ] walked me and
Mel through the [ __ ] Comedy Store
through the kitchen to a back [ __ ]
room we opened the door it's Jeffrey
Ross Dave Chappelle and [ __ ] Paulie
and we back there for an hour hanging
with Dave just talking it's great comedy
and music and yeah Comics are low-key
guys yeah they'll [ __ ] they're not
like who the [ __ ] yeah a lot of the
times you know you got to be a little
careful oh yeah I mean I I know we're
staying my welcome I was like well I was
like all right I'm done dude hey man
pleasure I'm looking forward to seeing
you tomorrow cool you know they got
knocked out Billy Burr had a there's a
smoking thing on the roof for the coffee
store I would I wanted to go last time I
saw it I saw everybody going up there
but I didn't know anybody I was I was
there with Rich Voss hanging out and I
was like man I want to go up and smoke a
cigar up there but I was smoking cigars
right in the front
boss annoys me so much
someone gave him a box of Cuban cigars
he doesn't smoke cigars
he calls me up
he's like I got these cigars the Cuban
they're really good this guy told me I
don't smoke you want him I go yes
anybody says do you want these yes yeah
100 I meet him at the cellar he entered
the box it's half empty
I go where are the roads you said a box
he goes I took the other half just in
case
I go in case of what I can use them to
like get on golf courses and stuff
you don't even have a humidor you don't
even know
come on man you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Cisco track Jesus killing America it's
covered with fruit and healthy food that
whole Cisco truck if you see a Cisco
truck it's murdering us that's where
we're fat Fox because of that company
everything's full of sugar mayonnaise
shouldn't come up in this yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] hate him right I heard I heard
one what is a ranch I heard this guy
won't quit no you know the Cisco he's
hand no Cisco but he's hand blowing uh
dirt right now I mean it's Lily dirt
this guy's good I gotta get you know
what I switched I think this guy's the
best landscaper I've ever seen in my
life
so uh
I heard a story one time Billy was
talking about Billy Bird was talking
about yeah right yeah I only call him
that because you called him that so I
call him Bill Murray but Bill was
telling a story about Versi showed up
with a bunch of cigars all the Cubans
and you were like they're not Cubans man
and bill was like dude you couldn't give
him that he couldn't just smoke it yeah
because I don't want to smoke a shitty
fake [ __ ] Cuban
you know what I mean
I laughed my ass off when he was telling
this story I was like oh yeah that's
Bobby you know what dude it's always
down in Mexico and they have the fake
ones they have the the they're all they
keep them in a window at a [ __ ] store
and they're all dry and probably they're
yeah there's a cigar tip for you if you
buy Cubans in Mexico they're fake that's
it
um
what is this the [ __ ] highway what
time is this [ __ ] man
um
anyway
uh I did have a Cuban resale I'm telling
you it kind of one recently humans don't
know partake of four a lot of loud cars
in Arizona yeah if you get a uh if you
get a wooden box with plastic on the
front and you know you could get a box
of cigars and scan it and it'll come up
on if you could do the the code it will
come up and tell you if it's real or not
yeah yeah I got about me and my buddy
went in on a box of Cubans it went
through uh it went through Czech
Republic and it was the uh the Monte
Cristo the yellow banded yeah the cute
you know the um but they were real I
mean they it took him a month to get to
us
um but then we waited two weeks to smoke
them and put them in the human over two
weeks and then we divvy them off they're
all right you know what man I mean for
the money right here look at man for the
money actually any cigar you can smoke
and maybe find a little taste out of it
I know when I go to Aruba I'm smoking
some Cubans that aren't Cuban but
they're all right they're not gonna kill
you yeah I just you know dude I got
Cubans he was passing them off like he
had a [ __ ] box of oil number fives
no it's like crazy yeah I'm sorry I love
you buddy but you gotta know and I want
him to know I want him to know that you
know I had somebody gave me a sandwich
we got exact box they were like here I
got these there how much did you pay
they were free I was like good listen
nobody's given free cubits they make
more money off of counterfeit cubers
than they do regularly oh [ __ ] a dude
they don't even make that many Cubans to
make the same amount of money let me ask
you this
[ __ ] Ari smokes a cigars just kind of
hate that because he's mad that you're
on the show I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
I don't give a [ __ ] I still like them
I'm waiting where the [ __ ] is this juice
special where the [ __ ] is going on it's
coming dude October October 26th that's
fine four days from now yeah it's coming
out this dude I can't wait out now
yeah we out go check it out I saw him go
by kill box first matter of fact you
hooked me up with it he he already was
[ __ ] cool he got me the best seats in
the house and I watched the juice
special this was like pre-covered right
and I bought his little [ __ ] grinder
with his [ __ ] face on it yeah yeah
and uh anyway uh Ari's [ __ ] I mean
listen what about Sir is he is he become
a connoisseur is he is a good cigar
smoker he's actually yeah he's there man
he's got a beautiful uh refrigerator a
wine fridge humidor yeah most people
don't know you can buy these for 200
bucks off yeah Amazon yeah they're for
wine but they're also for humidors you
get them you can get the humidor hookup
for cigars uh he's got he's I respect
him because he
only has good cigars yeah he does not I
have
great cigars I have Cubans down the
bottom boxes on the second of what
various stuff then I have my my father's
in tatawajes and then I have randos yeah
good ones but then I have a whole shelf
of [ __ ] so like not [ __ ] but mediocre so
when someone comes over that isn't a
cigar smoker I'll give him one of those
you have to take this because I have
that on the bottom right because that
low that keeps the the moisture correct
and then I have a three tier one right
so I have my [ __ ] excellent ones that
I [ __ ] that I hold on like the good
good ones I smoke on a rare occasion
then I had the ones that my everyday
smokers so my everyday smoke is like
the mj-12 by illusion I like the the
Tabernacle the wise man great Jesus
those are my those are my like every day
and then I have like the Oscar the
superfly or even the the Sumatra or the
Maduro
um I do like the uh
um the Oliva V yeah oh yeah so those are
my those are my everyday ones those are
some cigars you can get at most gas
stations now
yeah up in New York you can go to now
gas stations carry on yeah and they got
Olivas they got uh Romeo and Juliet it's
another good cigar not expensive mild uh
that's like an old school when I go to
old school every now and again depending
where I'm at yeah you know 100 yeah do
uh you um
you ever been to that place on 56th
Carnegie Carnegie's yeah love that place
yeah I think it's cool they got uh the
guy that sings uh he sings like uh Frank
Sinatra on Monday nights great place in
New York if you want to go yeah and have
a an enjoying night of cigars if you're
gonna go with your friends and drink and
there's a live uh live uh singer they
usually have jazz or him but it's old
school old school it's expensive you're
gonna spend some money but bring your
own cigar and you just do plate of cup
feet yeah yeah it was a ten dollar cut
fee 20 but it's worth it people don't
know that when you go to Cigar places
like that they charge if you don't buy
from them you get a cut fee which is
worth it I think it's worth it sometimes
yeah so I smoke the the bottom one they
had there was a Romeo and Juliet it was
20 bucks I'm like I'll just smoke that
so then I'm [ __ ] having a
conversation with Mel we're talking
about uh talking about a band or some
[ __ ] and then the bartender goes hey man
ah were you on the Warped one I was like
yeah I did you know I did a bunch of
work tours he goes oh me too my band the
next thing I know I was like Yo dude I
pulled out my little travel humidor I
was like dude check this out I just got
one of these they're they're new it was
a it was a McFly at the time was new and
I gave him an Oscar McFly he goes ah
cool and he came over
Melody had about nine or ten [ __ ]
Cosmos so she was half in the bag you
know and then uh
we smoked like three cigars right there
he started smoking my own yeah and then
uh we get to build 17 bucks ah that
[ __ ] I left a hundred there's nothing
better than when you have cigars the
great part about having a bunch of so
guys is giving them away yeah is that
dude I smoked this already you smoked it
yeah try it
um that just happened to me in Glendale
I was in I was doing the I did the Jim
Jefferies podcast so I had a little time
so I stopped I was like oh they found
this little cigar place it's the only
place in Glen where is he in Glendale
okay so if California so I [ __ ] go to
the cigar lounge or walk in and the dude
goes dude Rob Duke swings this I'm like
oh five there's some [ __ ] uh Mexican
guy
so now I'm like the celebrity man so a
[ __ ] bot so we're hanging out did you
say he's Mexican because you did the
accent yeah that's pretty much yeah this
is exactly how he said it you know what
I mean and uh so we hung out I had a
cigar and then um uh I gave him I was
like I go you know what man I have these
Superfly six by sixties that are the guy
gave me they're kind of rare to find I
haven't seen them around anywhere I
found him in that place in Paramus the
the biggest humor that Monte Cristo
humanoid Monte Cristo loud yeah so I I
got to Jr yeah so
um the [ __ ] that stuff I mean look at
this
I mean probably
day drinking in Scottsdale wow
that's um they're getting married she's
getting married
hmm anyway so uh
I found this place and I gave the guy uh
I mean if that's not alcoholism I don't
know what is
you know what I mean yeah that's not the
definition of alcoholism I wish I knew
the name of the place let's rent a huge
Golf Course
a golf cart and have some guy drive us
around just the main streets in it's two
it's not even one it's one o'clock in
the afternoon do you know that you can
you you can drive golf cars around here
like a car yeah I just saw it yeah
that's like a thing like people drive
golf carts around [ __ ] they're going
to wind up I know they're going to be at
my show and they're going to be
screaming and yelling they started
drinking in the Sun at one they're gonna
be at my show front row and talk to us
awesome Wild Wild West here man yeah hey
Mel is that mine
so you're gonna you you can't you yeah
leave it right here you can't go on
screen you have to hand it to me I'll
get it no no no no you can't we can't
have it it's only two Comics two cigars
yeah
grab those two creamers buddy I'll get
them all right don't order me around
okay
thank you
so I wish I knew the place in Glendale
but I don't but here's the deal I gave
them two cigars because that's the way
cigar people are yeah I gave them two
out of my humidor yeah he [ __ ] comes
back out he's got two [ __ ] real
Cubans partaga four and hand of me goes
here man next thing I know I'm like oh
man I'm gonna it's 20 minutes out of La
I said this is a place I'm gonna come
next time I'm here to smoke you know the
most generous comedian so far with
cigars is
Russell Peters no [ __ ] I did a show and
uh just for laughs as Gala I love him
he's so funny so nice
he [ __ ] he sent me a box of uh punch uh
double Corona Cubans whole box
it's like it's worth a lot of money yeah
and I mean just a great cigar so his
second time he's done it second box of
cigars he's given to me
and at a high end which I love you you
gave me a nice cigar it was in a it was
in a glass tube it had a had a picture
inside I think it was a Romeo and Juliet
Romeo and Juliet yeah it was a thousand
of these humidors made blood red humidor
with 50
um
50 cigars in each standing up straight
and inside of the box when you open it
up there's a piece of artwork from Frank
what's his name type artist Frank
or something like that
I don't know I gotta get his name I have
a bad memory but inside each cigar in
the tube was a his art piece of art so I
saved it so I still have that yeah save
it so I have this there's not that many
those that's a limited edition right so
yeah that's a high-end white dude Golf
Course right you know Donald Trump
[ __ ] Illuminati [ __ ] cigar I
smoked that when I came home from tour I
had done a tour on and uh played a bunch
of shows with Generation Kill and I came
home and I after like five weeks of
being on the road I made myself a nice
uh espresso and I just uh I had that
cigar I was like Bobby it's time I'm
having it here's the thing with that I'm
glad you did that but here's those
cigars came to me and they were done
hard I put them in my humidor my friend
Yuri told me what to do I got 80s a v to
80 packs
and you don't know this you don't need a
big fancy humidor you can get one of
those uh construction buckets that seal
good at Home Depot yeah gun cases throw
your [ __ ] cigars in those and then
get the babita packs throw them in there
that's a humidor I have a gun case for
that's my travel you don't need a fancy
one you know you spend 20 bucks and fill
it up but uh I put them in there for
three or four months I think I let them
sit I took them out they had plume no
Plumas I took them out of I had to wipe
them off individually from the plume all
the like the white stuff yeah because it
got a little crazy I wiped them off
individual gloves I had white gloves and
I wiped them off put them back in and
one of the best cigars in my human one
of the best smokes I've ever smoked I
agree it was it was delicious and
there's only four left so I have out of
the 50. I have I have um you know who uh
one shot one kill you ever smoke one of
those
okay one shot one kills a small boutique
company
um he's uh working for a rails now right
yeah
so years ago he did a one-off with
horioshi three so horioshi three is one
of the most famous tattoo artists in
Japan it's one of the most famous tattoo
artists in the world he does it with a
stick I flew to Japan and I got tattooed
by him wow so I'm at this I'm at the
that's amazing you flew all the way to
Japan to get tattooed by this guy yeah
where is it right here
I want to take a picture of that oh my
God yeah that looks like it hurt
the healing hurt
wow yeah so
um it's a piece of art on your leg right
so this guy's his famous artists right
and uh and uh so uh he um
he did a one-off with this guy uh uh
Edgar from one shot one kill
and he drew the the the artwork that
goes on the band and he made they made a
thousand of them
all right and
um
he also Inside the Box the he does uh
original piece of art that comes inside
the box and it's all numbered so I'm at
the I'm at the the PCA which is the
cigar uh uh convention in Vegas yep uh
where all the all the cigar companies
all come together and they give you the
new ones they show you the new ones they
get so I I get invited to this so I go
to I've been in the last two years last
two years [ __ ] you I want to go let's go
next year I'll put you on the list all
right come with me
come with me all right you've been my
guest okay all right
so uh I wasn't doing nothing what's up
this guy's still going
he's doing the sidewalk now yeah so uh
anyway
they make these cigars this is like
years ago this is like 2017. right so
I'm at the PCA and I I got into a
conversation with this just random dude
who I meet just just bullshitting right
right and uh I tell them the story I go
yeah man I have this [ __ ] piece of
art and I lost it in Hurricane Sandy I
had a so when I went and got tattooed he
gave me a piece of original art wow and
it got flooded my house got flooded and
I lost it and hit Sandy right
so
he says you know what I might have uh I
might have the artwork that comes inside
the box man if I if you know give me
your number and your address and I'll
[ __ ] right
so a month later
month later I get a box in the [ __ ]
mail I open it up he sent me a box of
the cigars wow
with three in it because that's all that
was left it was the last three and the
piece of artwork and then he sent me
like these three rare cigars that are
it's that were like one-offs for like
private parties or whatever and uh so I
have three of them
and I wanted to uh I wanted to smoke on
with you that was like I'm I've been
saving them for well what the [ __ ] I'm
right here why aren't we smoking because
um tomorrow we're gonna [ __ ] hang
them all right we should have smoked
those what time are you leaving Sunday
I'm leaving at five in the morning my
plane leaves at five so so we're gonna
have to smoke one tomorrow night after
the gig I'll bring them we're gonna
smoke I'm gonna have to pack in the
afternoon yeah you're gonna we're
hanging out man we're going we're going
late tomorrow so you know be ready we
need broads are getting married around
here so yeah anyway I've been saving it
for you how long have I had that what a
year
or since since July I've been saving
them from July well I brought you one of
the punches that Russell gave me oh no
[ __ ] so yeah it's the sky brought for
you all right well let's wrap this up
yeah what do you think you're at the end
it's still [ __ ] great I haven't lit I
haven't re-lit it once it's still great
I haven't had a gas it out I still love
this cigar
ette
one of the best this is it man when they
say you know I mean money does buy good
excellence and I think this is one of
them what would you rate it
it's a box a box if I could have a box I
would have a box
it's not a box for you
now
the box is 200 what would a box be 360
400 bucks four dollars for a box I add
this up can you add this up
it's 25 a cigar no 35 is to go 35 times
20.
that's a lot
375. no way more than that what are you
dumb yeah okay me too 100 700 bucks 700
bucks yeah I'm so stupid no I wouldn't
do that yeah I'm not spending 700 on the
boxes so guys unless it's the
[ __ ] this is great it's amazing
right you know what I I take it back
it's not about I'm not spending 700 on
this box I would spend 300 on this box
yeah it's not that yeah I would I would
I would do five
I'd do five I'd buy five of these and
I'd share them with people and when they
like certain events it would be on my
humidor in a certain space dude we're
gonna smoke let's smoke these yeah yeah
I would do that I wouldn't I wouldn't
spend 700 on a box
the only time I spent 700 a box I don't
know if I I mean I would but maybe
davidoff's a Davidoff Dominica Dominica
I think it's called or uh I don't know
700 a box if I was going to spend 700 on
a box
right seven of our time for 20 hours
that's about it hour and a half so maybe
30 hours right of my life better do the
math 7 20 times 30 is what
please don't do it yeah right so 30
hours of my life we're both dumb it's
more than 30 hours an hour and a half
times 20.
it is 30 is 24 Hours 27 62 hours did you
double what you said
30 times what
30 times first of all drop the attitude
okay I mean it would be 90 times 20. can
I help you with this that's the
challenge 90 minutes times 20. so now
we're at 4 42 000 minutes no 54 000 . 54
000 is how many divided by 60. just ask
Siri don't ask around my phone call
so yeah I think five of these all right
well there you go what do you got coming
up what do you got you got your album
out you got my album out I've been
running around doing Puck I was hoping
to go to New York I got a gig in
December in Albany
um Generation Kill Generation Kill we're
playing uh playing a benefit gig in
December and then I got a gig in uh in
New Haven in on January 14th I'm playing
um January 13th was a Friday night
Friday the 13th January playing in uh in
uh New Jersey at uh dingbats I want you
to come to that it's dude it's 40
minutes from here what date is it it's a
Friday it's January 13th it's tough yeah
this is a tough man but I know maybe
what you can do is go do your set and
then [ __ ] drive out tonight one of my
sets in in uh Des Moines yeah I don't
want you to I want you to do New York
that weekend all right we'll work it out
if I'm around I'm coming you
he's doing sober October I still can't
do more than three push-ups yes it takes
him all day all right check it out two
Comics too so guys if you're two comics
and you have the two exact same cigars
smoke them film it mic yourself don't be
morons use a good mic and uh
and uh make sure that uh you know you
got the video rated at the beginning
middle and end and then at the end let
me finish my thing ready at the end none
one five or a box
and talk about the cigar but then talk
about whatever you want send it to us
and we'll put it up on the uh YouTube
page as soon as we're done the
landscaper was done so yeah make sure
landscaper is working right next to you
when you film it and what are you gonna
do I hope you enjoyed the episode Rob
Dukes check out my special kill box
it's the loudest Showbox it was [ __ ]
awesome Fourth of July man go watch that
[ __ ] look like go to kill box Fourth
of July kill box we're watching both wow
that's what I did I watched them both
because they're both [ __ ] really good
kill box was dude I'm Sonia the thing
about Max had me [ __ ] choking my
friends had to ask me if I was okay
because I couldn't they laughing they
were [ __ ] dying but I was dying dying
have a kill box party rent it that's
what I did and we had a kill box get
some cigars and do your thing we did
that's exactly what we did Louis ck.com
get yourself that special and go to my
website and support my dates and then go
watch watch the movie too all right
he was [ __ ] awesome get the movie get
it all support us Nick Apollo is [ __ ]
we're not asking anymore we're just
filming it ourselves and we're giving it
to you yeah it was totally worth the
money I mean I I couldn't I was so glad
that I watched it because they were both
brilliant let's say goodbye to the
people
later people [ __ ] you Ari